dude it just comes with a territory
that's when you're in your creative man
you're gonna be crazy
you gotta accept the craziness
[Music]
do you wanna talk about kanye i do want
to talk about kanye
yeah so i only watched the first episode
because i have this rule i've got two
rules
the the first rule is if there's a movie
that involves animals as the
protagonists protagonist
i don't know where you're going with
this
i don't watch it i don't watch
the animals always die
so i don't watch it i have a rule i
don't want like if there's a war movie
and it's set in a period where they had
horses like braveheart or or the patriot
and the horses die in the war i don't
watch it i i just it's too much for me i
don't like seeing horses die i don't
like seeing the line get trampled i
don't watch that [__] the second thing
is if it's generally either scary or sad
i don't watch that either i'm not paying
money to get freaked out right i'm
paying money to be happy
yeah like my life sucks sometimes anyway
i don't need to like i want to pay money
to like make it not suck so i knew that
in episode two that was when his mom
died so i was like nope i'm not gonna
watch that so i only watched episode one
uh but by the way i've watched episodes
this bomb doesn't die yet uh that that
part uh
so they made it i thought they made it
they were playing the song hey mama like
over the preview
so you haven't seen any of the scenes
with his mom because those are the best
scenes
well yeah where she's like he's like i
bought a she's like uh you don't own a
house but you bought this chain and she
goes okay
i like the chicken kanye's nice this is
nice
yeah she was very supportive of him yeah
so um
dude okay so let's talk about the mom
all right so this kind of documentary is
frankly great and i'm kind of mad more
friends didn't tell me you gotta watch
this like i can see why maybe some
people don't like it but this is like
this is up my alley this is this is my
app dude
did you see the idea about how they're
basically it was just a guy you because
you asked yourself why is this where's
this footage from
why is this guy just walking around like
he's got a cam it's like a camcorder on
his shoulder why is this guy with kanye
when he's like on the street and
basically this guy was like
i saw
i forget the movie that he saw it was
called like
there's a movie where yeah hoop dreams
it follows four young like high schooler
kids or eighth grade kids he's like
let's see if they're gonna make it to
the nba and he's like i was inspired by
that and i thought kanye was gonna be
famous and so i just decided to follow
him around and this was before youtube
was around so it was weird that a guy
was with like a shoulder candy
totally weird what what luck for all of
us
that that guy so shout out to cootie the
guy who did it um he basically and by
the way i think they explain this more
later i haven't seen the whole thing so
i might not know something that's like
said in the documentary but like i've
only watched the first couple parts
so
he basically sees kanye and he's like
this guy's cool
and then drops everything is like i'm
gonna film this guy i'm gonna film this
random guy from chicago who wears a
retainer and is trying to be a rapper
and he's like a cool producer but like
you know who knows right like you know
most people don't make it as kanye says
in the documentary he goes yeah where i
grew up there's a whole bunch of guys
who were who who were just finna get
signed and guess what they're still
finna get signed they're just they're
always finna get signed
and so like you know that seemed like
the
the most likely path but like that's
amazing so this documentary is amazing
because he's got footage from before
everything when he's when he's got
nothing when nobody believes in him and
he's like you know trying to make it and
because because of that he's got all
this footage and other people also view
it as harmless it's like oh i don't know
why this guy got a camera what are you
doing with the camera out it's like i'm
filming a documentary for kanye all
right that's weird all right but i guess
come on in like
who knows
and so you see jay-z you see pharrell
you see all these like
legends in the game early on because and
in studio because they just have this
footage it's amazing
it was awesome i loved this documentary
it was cool that he looked up to a
couple guys like most deaf and common
and now those folks aren't even in the
same stratosphere as what he is exactly
he does and he surpassed them they asked
for his honor and he would
yeah and they were like um
all right fine kanye fine i'll
i'll come with you to this thing right
and it was awesome and
it's easy to say like when i watch it
now i'm like oh this is so obvious this
guy like has the it factor and of course
that's easy but there was a there was
one scene where he was in a record label
like reception room i think
and there was this woman just standing
there and he was like hey can i talk to
whoever and she kind of ignored him and
then he just started rapping he's like
well let me show you my rap and he plays
um he plays all falls down right i think
and which is like the hit of hits and
he's rapid and she's like get cameras up
for a minute and then eventually she
just like starts making phone calls and
she's like working and then she's like
excuse me like has to walk by because
there's something at the door and he's
playing all falls down before it like
became a thing and
it made me think of two things one
that's crazy that he kept getting after
it and two
even though all falls down is a total
hit i understand how if you heard it
it's just some crazy guy you'd be like
oh that's stupid yeah and it really
makes me respect people whether it's
people who invest money in a product or
people who find an artist or find art or
a trend people who can spot something
and be like i think that's it and if we
position it in the market this way this
is going to be a home run and it really
shows you how hard that is because that
woman and there was like three different
ladies walking around the room were 100
fans of that song they were like
they were like looked like young people
that were in the music industry and
they're working the way up they 100 were
about that song when it came out but
then
it didn't click and that is what i try
to imagine i'm like what what is my all
falls down today did i skip over
anything today and i found myself asking
that after i saw that documentary 100
because you just see people who are
writing them off people who are just too
busy doing their work that they missed
this absolute gold mine that's like
literally he's
putting it in your face saying please
please like check me out right and like
and it's easy like when something's
popular it's easy to appreciate it's
greatness
when something is some random guy in
your way it really takes something
special to spot that talent and it made
me want to be that guy right it made me
want to be that parent so like i wrote
down a bunch of notes which is weird
because like who writes notes while
documentary but i was like there were
things that stood out to me that were
like
real life lessons or just amazing
moments that were in this so i'll give
you one he's rapping with his mom his
mom his mom was an english teacher and
she's like what's that one you used to
say like i was at the playground and
then they said boys came around and then
and she's like doing it and he does it
and she's like oh i love that one kanye
like an audience of one it's like all he
really had at that point was one fan it
was like his mom and she's like that's a
million dollars right there she goes i
always used to tell you that right
that's a million dollars right there and
he laughed he goes ain't got a million
dollars yet and like now he's a
billionaire right and so it's like and
she's like no i'm telling you that's a
million dollars and then
he he tells her some good news he's like
mom uh mtv is going to film me for their
like you heard it here first thing for
emerging artists like unknown artists
can you believe that they're going to
film a documentary
okay can you believe that and she goes i
can believe it the way you are she goes
you writing tracks it's like watching
michael jordan shooting free throws and
then she goes and then she goes um
she goes you know you you work so hard
you kept going you keep going up it's
bound to pay off so yeah i believe that
kanye for people like you you're special
kanye and like
and she's not saying it
there's no difference when you say
you're doing a really good job with this
yeah this is good
you've got me bought in this is really
good and so so she was you know there's
a difference when somebody says
something like you're great
versus like when somebody genuinely
believes in you and they're not just
trying to pump you up and they just have
a quiet confidence about them like she
wasn't going overboard and wasn't saying
like don't worry you're gonna make it
she was just saying like
of course i believe it
like yeah i'm not surprised
and she wasn't critical so he comes back
and she goes kanye when are you gonna
buy a house and she he goes i don't know
yet but check this out and he pulls out
this chain i don't know what was on it
but he was like i could have bought a
house but i bought this instead and she
goes well
that's it's all right it's pretty nice
good job i like that kanye yeah yeah
and she's like so again so supportive
and such a believer and that's like you
know a thing that moms do but it's just
like you know that's mad respect on that
and um and so most moms don't do that by
the way i don't think most moms do that
i feel like you know you know like a lot
of people like dude i have the best mom
it's like well you know yeah yeah trust
me there's a lot well i i i think that
there's a lot of shitty parents out
there and then i think that most parents
are just
that most parents are just are okay it's
just like a distribution just like
everything else uh and she was very
special and right single mom too right
no doubt single mom and uh hey you know
he opened up her fridge and there's like
literally like like like wine and milk
well there's a quart of milk and like a
quarter a quart of rose or something
like that by zinfandel
and then like he's and he uses that like
in his song later or whatever and so
there's a couple other things so that so
he goes um
uh
he so i'm just gonna can i read you to
some of these notes i just keep going so
there's one scene where he's he's um
oh no she goes
she's trying to warn him and so she goes
you have this confidence that kind of
like um
you know but i want you to make sure you
stay humble and and like obviously
that's you know been a challenge for
kanye over time as he's like i am jesus
now and so and she's like remember a
giant looks in the mirror and sees
nothing
and like i still to this point i don't
know what that meant and kanye clearly
also didn't know what that meant in the
moment and then she tries to explain she
goes
she goes don't she goes don't make
yourself less of a star a star is going
to look like a star you can't be a star
and then say i'm not a star you can't
have you she goes you got to have some
oomph about you i just love that like
that's a there's a that's a phrase to
live by it's like i have something about
me like that can mean anything in any
situation and it's the right thing
and then she goes she goes don't just go
to the mirror and say no i'm not all
that thank you very much i'm not all
that i'm not a star like yeah you'd be a
star but be humble at the same time and
she goes you and he goes you're saying i
don't do a good job of that she goes no
you do a good job with that but you got
to make sure you keep doing a good job
of that and like those are like you know
kind of like that's a seed that's been
planted right
and so gosh he's great so there's that
one and then there was like all these
moments where
all right the importance of identity
right so
he says from the be so at the time he's
known as a great producer he produces
the beats that jay-z uses on his big
blueprint album and people know him as
that everyone loves him as a producer
everybody wants him as a producer but he
wants to be a rapper
yeah he was upset about it he's upset
and so he goes into this one he's in the
hallway at the record label which which
by the way a lot of people forget do you
realize how much he produced before he
actually got famous no that's kind of
crazy it's pretty crazy like the big one
was h to the izzo right and there was
like there's like dozens more i can't
think of anything off the top of my head
but there was dozen more where you like
wait you did that and he did it before
he had his own thing yeah exactly
exactly and he was great at it and then
he's like he talks about he's like yeah
people want my b say oh oh i want okay
can i get one can i get i need a b give
me a beat he's like and then then they
hear my song yo i hadn't heard this
where'd you get this he goes that's my
[__] i use that for me and he's like
he's like trying to like on one hand he
needs to sell beats to pay for life
but every time he does it's a step away
from where he wants to be in a way like
to be a rapper and so he's in this
hallway and this guy's trying to hype
him up because he's like oh you got the
documentary crew so he puts his arm
around him it's like the the managing
director at rockefeller records and he's
like
you know this right here kanye west he's
the best rapper producer in the game
best rapper producer in the game period
and then kanye's like kind of like upset
and he's like what he goes why you guys
say that man that's like saying i'm the
best kid rapper in the game he's like
what man i said you're the best rapper
producer in the game he goes i'm just a
rapper if i'm the 50th best rapper just
say he's the 50th best rapper don't call
me the best rapper producing the game
that's whack all them are whack i'm not
that i'm a rapper and like
think about what's going on at that
moment right he's like fighting to get a
record deal where most people are in
desperation mode like they'll take what
they can get and instead he's got this
identity and the whole world is trying
to pull him to just be a producer
because that's what's in it for them
like that's proven
and that helps you know helps them make
hits and you know why aren't you just
happy pat you on your head say you're a
great producer and he had this identity
in his head so strong that i think 99
people out of 100 in his position
would just become
a
producer because the whole world was
pulling him in that direction and it was
a faster
success and the money was there and the
success was there and he didn't have to
grind as hard
as he did to try to prove himself as a
rapper but he had it in his head no i'm
a rapper and if i'm the 50th best rapper
i'd rather be the 50th best rapper than
the best rapper producer and i just it
was such an example to me of like people
will stay consistent with their identity
and so you kind of got to ask yourself
like what is my identity like if i said
sam are you what's your job sam
what do you do
uh right now my job is i do if i just
say what like who are you what do you do
for work what do you do for a living
i'm a business person okay you're a
business person so if all of a sudden
it doesn't matter what hubspot offers
you right like okay you're vesting out
your deal you you that's great but let's
say any company comes to you and say sam
we'd like to make you the vice president
of marketing operations at biggest
company in the world and you're going to
get this and that
you're not going to do it because it's
not consistent with your identity you're
like i'm a business person i'm an
entrepreneur yeah so entrepreneur i
can't be an employee if i'm an
entrepreneur
they're two separate things and like in
the same way you know you're not gonna
do heroin because you're not you're
somebody who doesn't do heroin you don't
even have to weigh the pros and cons of
it it's just really not a discussion for
you it's not part of who you are it's
not like i'm trying not to do it it's no
i just i don't do that i do do this and
i don't do that and so those lines you
draw for yourself are so important on
identity
and i would argue so there's this book
called 48 laws of power have you read it
no but i've heard of it all right it's
awesome so he's got this one chapter
where he says you always have to
reinvent yourself and he gives a bunch
of examples about that and the reason
why you want to reinvent yourself is the
person who you can't peg down typically
can become the most powerful because
there's something about changing your
self that it does a couple things first
this whole act as if thing it's real so
if you like act like you're gonna be an
expert
artist or something and you work harder
you can eventually become that but you
kind of gotta act as if second it kind
of reinforces habits so you see like no
i'm a healthy person therefore i don't
do unhealthy things and third it gives
you this aura of mystery and people who
have mystery surrounding them typically
are powerful right and uh and there's a
ton of good examples about this like a
really interesting and easy one because
she does it so
clearly is lady gaga so like oftentimes
she'll reinvent herself so at first she
was this like kind of just normal like
white lady playing on the piano if you
see her like when she's a little bit
younger then she becomes like this
weirdo person where she like puts meat
on her body then she transforms and
becomes um
she starts playing jazz with tony
bennett you're like what the heck lady
gaga's doing that what the hell is that
now she like just got done doing some
acting and she was a great actor so like
constantly reinventing themselves i
think arnold schwarzenegger has done a
really good job
yeah you just you've got to reinvent
yourself consistently and kanye has done
that where he's actually changed himself
and i think inventing reinventing
yourself you actually need to make the
decision you could be like i am this
now i am this exactly that's okay and
then you got to choose that identity
and after a while then you could be like
all right great i that season was this
season had a beginning in the middle and
now it's come to the end what's the next
season of me and you can actually pick
and choose what those inventions are and
i when i read that when i was a little
bit younger that kind of changed my
perspective on things when i went to the
tony robbins event it was a perfect
example of what you're talking about so
he he tells the story he's like you know
he's like yeah there was this kid i was
working with or this kid i met and kid
was overweight and he wanted to be fit
but he was talking about oh you know
it's hard i'm working so hard on time to
exercise blah blah and he's like he
wanted to be in a relationship and we
saw a woman beautiful woman i said well
go talk to her then and he didn't want
to go talk to her well why would she
want a guy like me i'm too young she
looks older than me you know i don't
have a good job she probably wants a guy
you know who's got you know something
going for him look at my clothes i don't
look good so he didn't want to go talk
to her
so he talks about all these aspects of
his life his health his relationship his
career it's like what do you want to
you're working as a busboy right now at
a restaurant what do you want to be
going and doing i want to be over there
i want to run that dealership over there
you know all right so why don't you go
apply for it why would they hurt me i
got no college education right like
coming up with all the reasons why like
labeling himself all these identities
that he's not right i'm overweight no
college education too young too dumb too
fat two whatever right and people do
this all the time and so
he's like he draws he basically talks
about the turning point for this kid
he's like he drew a line and he said um
no experience like no experience what
are you talking about yeah no experience
yeah yeah i don't have i'm not stuck in
all the old ways like all those other
[__] right like i got fresh
ideas i got the energy of a young
stallion i'm not like some 50 year old
guy who you know is dragging into work
every day yeah i got no experience i got
the best experience no experience right
or like why would this woman want to be
with me because i got that you know he
just turns it around like what's the
truth is the truth
that you have no experience or the truth
that you have fresh ideas and young
energy and you'll you'll hustle harder
than anybody else to prove to prove
yourself because you have this is your
your track record right and so he does
that for each one of the things and then
it's like oh you know at the end it's
sort of like you know that kid's me and
he shows a picture of himself before and
where he was living and how he was
working and how he turned himself around
that's good and he says in this thing he
goes you know right now you guys see me
on stage and i got this i have energy
and confidence and i have all these like
this inside wisdom or all these things
that people praise me for he goes what
people don't realize is i created this
tony robbins [__] i created him
and uh like and i just thought that was
so powerful of a way of thinking like
you can create that that thing you want
to be that the ideal version of you you
get to create that and the people who've
done it they just created it they chose
that identity and then they just lived
up to that day by day
and like you know there's a the kanye's
like a you know a great example of like
literally speaking it into existence he
says a ton of stuff on there like
people are going to know me without my
last name it'll just be kanye at some
point
and he's and i
go ahead no go go for it
when i was watching that
it also reminded me of this other thing
and here's a really small example so you
sean are
you're you're i don't know what you are
i i don't create creative is one word
but that's not the most effective word i
would say your
whatever
it requires to be a good like
storyteller and podcast host that's what
you are so it's like a mixture of
creativity performing and a bunch of
other stuff and what i've come to accept
is like so i always joke that sean is
always like usually two minutes late
he's usually always two minutes late to
stuff and at first that made me angry it
doesn't make me angry anymore now
because what i know is in order to be
good in order for you sean to be sean
and be good at these things that means
by nature you're gonna be the opposite
of good at these other things right like
that's just what that's just what it
comes with like so like if you want
someone like so it's like well you know
you can't be this amazing athlete and
have time to do all these other things
like in order to be an amazing athlete
you gotta train all the time so like i
just accept that like well i want him to
be good at this therefore i accept that
maybe sometimes i'll just he'll just be
two minutes late and when kanye acts
like a crazy person online
and he says all this crazy [__] about
kim kardashian and he types in all caps
on twitter and [__] people are like this
guy's crazy like what's he doing and i'm
like well
that's what we need
being crazy is good like that's why we
got all this gold and i love those crazy
people and you ca and so what i've
learned is like in order to be great
you're going to be
messed up in some other in some other
categories
the um the mr beast thing i was talking
about the beginning he said something
just like this he goes
uh like joe rogan asks like you know
what was it like you know what would
your friends think or whatever he goes
uh he's like at first my friends just
thought it was weird like nobody that
wasn't a popular thing to make videos
and then they just got sick of it
because all i ever wanted to talk about
was making youtube videos they would ask
me about other stuff or try to talk to
me about other stuff i just didn't have
any interest in anything else i was just
obsessed with making great videos
and it's all i wanted to think about and
um i remember there's a there's an
interview with conor mcgregor it goes on
bbc it's like one of the bigger like
it's like not just like an mma guy
covering conor asking about him it was
like bbc world or something like that
was going to interview
and they asked him some question or
there was like some small talk you know
about like about like the news or the
game and he's like oh yeah you know both
teams play hard he says something
generic and then the camera cuts at his
documentary crews filming because i have
no clue who those teams are he's like i
don't follow any i don't think i don't
follow sport i don't follow news he goes
um
because i don't know anything about
anything and i don't want to know
anything about anything i just am
obsessed with my with my craft i have
lost my mind to my craft and um i've
seen it and so you know it's like this
kind of inspiring thing that you see as
like a common
what are the common denominators of
greatness you i wouldn't say you have to
do anything because there's many ways to
win
but these do these things do show up
often right they sort of rhyme with
success is like
this obsession the sort of singular
obsession with something or identity
seeing yourself as being becoming
something even when the rest of the
world doesn't see it having that one
believer like your mom right like so
like if i was gonna say like the lessons
from kanye which i think is what this
episode is turning into it's like you
know number one it's like you know the
power of that one believer like his mom
number two is like the power of identity
number three is um
is like
so he has this moment where he goes
uh some somebody said something they go
um
they go you know do you think it's
harder for you because you're from
chicago and because you have this
background as a producer so people don't
take you seriously as a rapper
he goes he just goes he goes the way i
feel is anything that anybody ever tells
me is a disadvantage i'm gonna make it
my advantage
and then he basically if you watch the
documentary that's exactly what he's
doing he's like
okay i'm pigeonholed as a producer well
i'm gonna make the dopest beats for
myself and i'm gonna use my beats as
currency so he's like yeah i supply
beats to jay-z guess what i get jay-z to
do a hook on my first album which he's
not gonna do for like some random
no-name rapper but because i build this
credibility i'm gonna i'm gonna use that
as my currency or like he gets in this
car accident and his jaw is wired shut
it's like i'm gonna turn that to my
advantage how did he turn a disadvantage
like for a rapper having a jaw wired
shut through the wire he creates a song
called through the wire rapping about
his time
and then you know the first line is like
you know
about drinking ensure like you know
other people make pancakes i just drink
scissors you know just the syrup because
he can't eat solid foods right
so he writes his hit song when he's got
the broken jaw and he only also says his
other heroes i was laying there i
couldn't do nothing back there there's
no like cell phones or anything so he
had no smartphones so he's just like
sitting in the hospital doing nothing
for seven days he goes i was laying
there and i decided
i'm gonna be
the best dressed rapper in the game he's
like because he's watching music videos
so they they put music videos on there
but they couldn't put the volume high so
he couldn't like bump to the music was
just watching other rappers
so he turned the disadvantage into
advantage which was he realized all
these rappers dressed the same way and
it's this one style i'm gonna address it
back then and now he's a fashionable
billionaire you know
and back then rap fashion was horrible
it was just like it was like a
basketball jersey and like baggy cheese
yeah it was the worst so he did a good
job let me ask let me ask you a question
real quick
don't say their names because you might
have to insult them but the three
wealthiest people you know okay what is
what around what do you think their net
worth is each
um about
the ones like i know like i know well
like somebody not just like somebody
i've met yeah someone is like a friend
who you know about some of their
personality traits in their personal
life yeah i would say like somewhere
between like 300 million and 700 million
i like i know them like i know about
their like real life not just like the
surface level stuff
of those people how many of them
have this trait of being obsessed and
and to the point where if a normal
person a non-wealthy person saw their
life they would be like dude you're
weird or the way that you're handling
this is wrong you know you're
how many would say something like that
100 of them um 100 of them
what are examples of
yeah so one of them uh
they worked so hard on their business
they were so obsessed that like their
family members used to come to the
office and say you gotta come home like
you just you're working too hard we're
afraid and when they sold their company
like 45 days later they had like a heart
surgery because they had like worked
themselves that hard during that time
another one
i remember the day after they became
worth over 100 million dollars i was i
knew them well
that that same night they were up till
three in the morning working on their
like new project that had like no no
like you know less than 100 customers
and like clearly they'd already made it
and it's like for them to stay up fixing
bugs in this like test flight
product
that was you know at three in the
morning that day like
most people would be chilling hard for
it'd go on a bender for a year like
wired very differently third person
they're not just obsessed in their work
life they're obsessed with kind of
anything
um so they they like it's like if they
get into like some random hobby or sport
they just take it to like a level that's
not like common or like they're a
hardcore gamer or they they just like
get re they have an obsessive
personality it's not just an obsession
with work or money that just happens to
be the game that pays out in a points
called dollars
but they just get obsessed with any game
that like catches the catches their
their their interest
yeah that that rings true to all the
people i that i know do you have an
example i'm trying to
yeah so um our our mutual buddy um
um i i wonder if i could i'm actually
not gonna say his name so well
i'll say it yeah i could say it jack
smith so the chair like he the building
of the chair right that's an example
well i'll give you a different one so
he's obsessed with
if he buys anything he'll buy 30 of them
and at his house i've seen it he's got a
google spreadsheet he tracks every item
and every category of thing that he's
bought and he ranks it so if you ask him
about chocolate he actually has a
spreadsheet with literally a hundred
pieces of chocolate he goes i tested all
of them here's the best one
that i think is the best when we got
married my wedding gift from him was
roughly a thousand dollars of stuff that
he considered the best and it was so
weird like the best socks the best
underwear the best lotion and he's so
obsessed with this that amazon multiple
times has banned him from having an
account and so he has to create
different credit cards just to continue
getting an account and he's so he's just
obsessed with stuff right um and he's
he's incredibly wealthy and he probably
got he probably got wealthy when he was
28 really young but he's just crazy
obsessed with stuff to the point where
like
i i just i just that's i just accept
that's he's just an oddball right so
yeah that's one example
let me give you another one that i
thought was kind of uh
like one of the lessons
the lesson number i don't know what
we're on now lesson five from kanye
closed mouth don't get fed
so i i don't know if you've seen this
scene where he goes into he kind of like
just like he
there there's like a point where like
the record label
is not like paying for like the studio
time because like you know they're they
kind of like put them on the shelf
they're like
they weren't sure about them they didn't
want to put the money into like
promoting them and getting them to
record and all the stuff so he's like
pulling in favors some way somehow so he
goes to like
he he asks jamie foxx who he's like made
beats for before he's like hey i want to
come over oh you got the studio in your
house yo you mind if i just record
something real quick and like boom uses
the studio and then gets jamie foxx to
do vocals and that becomes the vocals on
one of his tracks
yes so jams then there's one with jay-z
he gets into the studio with jay-z
jay-z's recording and he's like yo uh
you might have a referee real quick and
he's like yeah okay yes you know i'm not
gonna say no
and he just freestyles on the spot with
no backtrack
for jay-z to his face like a one-on-one
like basically just one manner finding a
poem to another man it's like kind of an
amazing thing that's happening
and then jay-z you see him like start to
nod his head he just starts to like he's
like i like it
he lets him do a hook on jay-z's uh like
lets him do a verse on jay-z's track
and then jay-z says out loud in the
studio he goes i had no idea he goes but
that's he goes that just shows you
closed mouth don't get fed
and like and then they and then they
catch on the documentary the guy cootie
the recording guy he goes uh jay-z is
like leaving and cootie shoots his shot
too he goes he goes oh man what do you
think about kanye west and he goes he's
a kanye west man he's he's got it he's
gonna be big and he goes up and then he
goes he goes you think so he goes i'll
putting my money on it
and he walks up and does like the jay-z
laughter walks out the studio and they
capture that and they're like yes we got
like basically an endorsement from jay-z
that's gonna help us keep going and it's
just one instance after another of like
in the moment of truth
he didn't sit around and wait he shot
his shot and like you know closed mouth
don't get fed and i just think that's
like how did you how did you remember
all this were you literally just what
the pen and paper take on my phone
i would write notes i would just write
like
i'd write like it literally says closed
loud because i misspelled it typing fast
close laughs don't get meth
don't get fed jay-z
and then i and then i thought about it
right like because is this this is on
your on your iphone apps no it's app
note
and you do this for all your all things
like that yeah i just have notes for
everything like i have i have a thing
called
jokes and i'm like slowly building a
stand-up comedy set over time like
eventually i'll collect enough funny
things i'm like oh that could be a joke
i'll put it there god i find that to be
amazing because i watch the same thing
but you remembered so much more than i
did
i was just ups i was into it man i i
just saw so many lessons and i i
remember like there's so many moments of
my life like i bet you have one too
where's which is like
do you have a closed mouth don't get fed
moment like this one jump to mind or
those i'll tell you mine and i bet you
you have one
i probably have a few but i i i you know
as you can expect because i got big
mouth i typically have always
i've done a good job of speaking up
what's yours
like when i was in college i uh
at the time i thought i was gonna be a
doctor so i was pre-med i took the mcats
i was ready to graduate and go to med
school and just for fun i took a
blow-off class the easiest class offered
on duke campus was called getting rich
and obviously that changed the direction
of my life and one of the classes so the
teacher was basically she would bring in
somebody who had made it in some world
and they would come and just talk to us
so this guy was uh was this the most
popular you told me about this was class
to get into because it was like highest
highest rated of easiness of fun
and like that on ratemyprofessor.com
that that professor had a chili pepper
next to her name that means she's hot
so it was like all the high scores
so i got in and i was sitting in class
one day and the guy was a hedge fund guy
i think
and he was talking about his career he's
like all right enough about me like what
about you guys who's doing something
cool who's who's got a business that
they're trying to try to who's got a
business that they're that they're
running
or who's got a business they want to
launch and he started looking around the
class he basically scanned from left to
right he goes pitch me like that's what
i do i invest so so pitch me and he
lives from left left right no witness
crickets nobody's you know you've never
seen a quieter group of smart people and
nobody's that nobody raised their hand
i'm at the very edge of the class on the
right so i kind of had the advantage if
i had a moment to like
assess the fork in the road yeah
and the the night before me and my
friends had had that dumb idea for why
isn't there a chipotle for sushi oh dude
we can make that like there was a
chipotle on campus and we want or
there's a subway on campus and we we
wanted to build a version of that fast
casual thing for sushi i thought it was
a funny idea i had been pitching it the
night before to my friends where i was
safe
and now here was this guy saying pitch
me an idea and nobody's saying [__] and
then i had this thing in my eye like
back to identity i had this thing which
was like
you know you're the cool kid or
something not the cool kid i mean i
definitely wasn't quick at school but i
just felt to myself like
i'll take the sh i'll take the shot like
in basketball terms like if in the
moment of the clutch moment i'm not
gonna be afraid to shoot i might miss
but i'm not afraid to shoot
and so
i did it i raised my hand and he goes
all right finally what you got and i
pitched the idea and he goes that's a
terrible idea he just like blew me off
and like but he's like but you know let
me tell you like he's like even if you
go and do that and he like gave this
lesson which was like this is america
like it's the only country on earth
where you get rewarded for failing like
you can go fail at a business and people
will give you positive credit for trying
he's like most countries that's just not
how it works and he goes he goes you
know the other thing is a lot of you
guys might want to work at a hedge fund
someday or investment bank or whatever
guess what the first three-fourths of
your resume is all gonna look the same
it's only the bottom the other section
that's gonna have anything different
between you and the next kid who also
was honorable student did good on the
sats and then you know graduated with a
3-5 gpa so like that's the only way that
you're going to get differentiated so
you go do your sushi restaurant it'll
lead you you know it it'll help you in
what you want to do even if it fails and
that's like pretty much exactly how it
played out
this was a good conversation because of
how much you care
i i thoroughly enjoyed this i just i
barely said a word but i enjoyed it what
do you think ben i it's so evident when
one of us is like incredibly passionate
about the topic
yeah and
what do you guys feel like is the kanye
pod in the zeitgeist like do you think
that most of your friends are watching
it right now
well everyone knows what it is i think i
think a lot of people are watching it uh
like i've talked to maybe like i don't
know it's like you know one of the big
things on netflix is always like oh
you're watching the thing on netflix
that's at the top yeah like i am yeah
wait ben you you haven't seen it i have
seen it yeah i watched it yeah i think
that like i'm the only one of us who
finished it actually i watched the the
third part is uh is not as good as as
the first two though so you guys the
first part was great so have you are you
guys watching euphoria
no but i've i've seen
i've seen a couple episodes at the
beginning dude that [__] got me shook
you gotta watch that like yeah
apparently like if you're a parent like
it's just like yeah nightmare scenario
well it's this this lady
what's her name she's like half white
half black zedelia or something
and she just knocks it out the park man
this girl is so freaking good it just it
was it was wonderful acting she killed
it
i was really i
sarah and i both cried watching it wow
and that's got like a bunch of seasons
right
like two or something okay yeah i think
two you got to watch that it's so good
man this lady's such a good actor then
why'd you ask if it's in the zeitgeist
you think it's not or where'd you buy
jesse yeah i just like i
would think that it would kind of reach
like maybe not tiger king because that
was like a phenomenon but i was hoping
because i loved it so much that this
documentary would be like the thing on
netflix and that's true that like a
third of my friends have seen it that's
true it's not like as popular but his
craziness is pop like the whole thing
that he's doing with that with the guy
who's dating kim what's what's his name
pete davidson davidson that thing is
like even that's because that's kind of
overshadowing it
yeah that could be right
his crazy's coming out hard
i think part of the reason i liked it is
part of the reason it's not like getting
that big which is essentially for the
first episode for the first part he just
like has old footage of kanye and kind
of just lets it run with like a little
bit of narration
and it's so it's not that much of like a
a narrative story arc that sucks you in
he just kind of like lets you be a fly
on the wall
ben knowing what you know you had a
podcast called raising a genius
is it possible to raise a genius like i
i didn't you're you're i i didn't like
that podcast because you didn't do the
best job of like just telling me the
answer so like i listened to that also
he did get tell the answer but i feel
like
it was too narrow it was like the guy
raised three chess champions okay i get
that you can raise a chess champion
does that mean you can raise a genius or
that you can
out practice people at a game of chess
right like
you know
so i think those are two different
things
well like okay
can the encouragement that donna
whatever donda west can the incur
encouragement that she gave him
be
a huge factor or a small factor
i think it's a factor um
the polgar method this guy laszlo polgar
had a very specific method and i don't
think it would work all that well for
rapping because it is oriented towards
like
outcome driven
like it'd be good for raising uh
like a guitar player or a chess champion
or a swimmer or like those kind of like
very discreet you can teach people
exactly or a tennis player would be
really good but like
a rapper something more creative i don't
know if you can like
it's almost like if it's creative it has
to come from within you can't have
someone else come out and like try and
raise it but do you think that that her
encouragement of him made him confident
or he was born confident
i think
watching
that documentary it was crazy to see
some of the mannerisms that were the
same between her and kanye and i was
like oh there's something genetic about
this like yes it was her encouragement
but it's also like whatever he has he
kind of got from her and probably would
have had it anyway
i read this book called the blueprint
gene and it kind of changed my opinion
where like 85 of everything is genetics
that's kind of where i am now i'm like
even if she was rude to him maybe he
still would have killed it
dude when she was rapping she was good
she's just like reciting his rap well
yeah my mom would not be able to do that
because she wasn't she was an english
teacher right so clearly she was
interested i mean it's very related and
also he said he's been like making beats
since like sixth or seventh grade like
11 or 12 and so it's the same sort of
thing it's like
yeah by the time you're 25 you're gonna
be really [__] good at something
you've been doing for like over 15 you
know over 10 years basically at that
point um
and at like a formative stage where
you know when you're 12 and you get
obsessed with something you can kind of
just like do it pretty much non-stop and
get really good at something because you
can pick stuff up so fast you don't have
any other things to go do
right no that it was a good documentary
there was it got me thinking a lot that
was a good that was a good one
i'm just not gonna i just i couldn't
watch the rest because i i knew she was
gonna die and it and it was i was being
it made me sad just watching them
together it i got i choked up a couple
times seeing them together
yeah it was she was she was like
touching yeah
yeah she was supposed to um
the third part is like kind of
interesting because it goes it's like a
20-year time jump and then goes into
like a lot of stuff he's going through
now and kind of the weirdness and
running for president and like all that
and like
at the end cootie's just kind of like
yeah man i don't know pretty weird you
know like he doesn't really have
anything to say about it he's just like
kind of baffled as well dude it just
comes with a territory that's when
you're in your creative man you you're
gonna be crazy
you gotta accept the craziness he's so
crazy do you remember when he went to
trump's office to show him his version
of air force one
like he's he like drew up what air force
one should look like he's he's always
a genius he's a true genius
all right that's the episode
[Music]
you